so much like our US and UK colleagues we
went to a Nintendo switch event a few
days ago and one of the games we played
there is Simic lips mm-hmm so it's a
little puzzle game that you're
encouraged to play in co-op although I
believe you can't play it in
single-player as well if you can't find
another person who's willing to enjoy
you're playing a puzzle game with them
what did you think of it Dan
I really liked it it's kind of reminds
me it looks a lot like loco Roco on PSP
it's got a real flat kind of nice
good-looking aesthetic oh yeah so you've
got these lovable like pink and yellow
colored shapes and basically what you
can do is cut each other into different
shapes and you need to be certain shapes
to get through the level yeah so there's
different things that you need to
achieve in each level to be able to get
to the end of it yeah basically it
started off quite simple you had to make
like a simple shape like a heart or I
think we had to make one where each of
us had a small segment cut out but then
it got really complicated it did it got
super complicated like three or four
levels in to the point where actually I
I'd have to say this is not a kids game
at all like I got to a point about four
levels in where we were like oh this
isn't just about rotating slightly left
or right and becoming a heart this is
actually dissecting what the mission
even is for the level but yes doesn't
tell you and then being able to achieve
it with somewhat complicated platforming
in addition to being totally the right
shape and I guess we should point out
that the way to cut your shapes is you
use your body against the other person's
body to cut out the shapes so it's kind
of trying to figure out the best
position of your body to cut the perfect
shape that you need so for example one
of the things we had to do was get a
ball into a hoop yeah
and it's it's really really difficult
cuz it is I think it's physics based as
well so getting that ball in you're
trying to make a wedge and then trying
to fling it with each other it's just
it's very very complicated but I had a
really great time with it I really loved
it I played it twice and I thought it
was really great we only had a 10-minute
session with it so it's hard to speak to
how much the difficulty ramps up or
anything like that
I got a little
of the levels personally but it was more
complicated and interesting than what I
expected it to be I think playing co-op
on the Nintendo switch works really well
because obviously each of you gets a joy
cone controller there are certain
buttons associated with cutting each
other into different shapes with jumping
with crouching down everything you need
to do to move forward in the levels by
getting yourself into the right position
the joy cones are great but they are
quite small they're very small and the
the thumbsticks I've noticed are in the
center of the actual controller so it's
a little bit strange but I never found
it a problem I found them quite
comfortable the only thing for me was so
we I'm pretty sure you can play this in
a bunch of different modes obviously the
switch can be played on the TV on
handheld a bunch of different ways we
were playing it with a little screen and
we have the joy Cove controllers just in
front of it my eyes are pretty crappy
and I had a little trouble seeing the
outlines that we needed to fit into and
stuff like when our tails for our little
shapes needed to be off to the left
instead of their right I couldn't really
identify that with where we're sitting
in this relatively dark room so
something like that it might be better
on a TV than if playing it on that
little toy yeah I think I think
definitely if you're gonna play to play
off you definitely want to play it on a
big screen I think I think it's it's
quite hard to play but I mean around but
yeah if before you've got as a switch in
your house
I'd still in a pod who wants to maybe
cut a piece out of your little paper
character okay
totally yeah pretty fun puzzle game
check it out if you like we've got a
bunch of other switch impressions on
site so be sure to check back to
GameSpot
you
[Music]
you